[Music]
in poor baby news
oh that comes per man uh-huh
submitted by FBI surveillance van oh
yeah
toddler is allergic to water including
her own tears looked up and her own
sweat that [ __ ] sucks dude what
happens what is she gonna do for like
everything
yeah she's poor a little girl so how
does she drink water so breast milk as
of right now it's not affecting
internally it's only external but her
mom is really scared that eventually
you'll develop where she can't even have
water how you gonna be a nurse to water
though you need water in like your
body's like 80% water even her even her
own tears of sweat thanks crazy baby go
rash or is it like she might die she
gets hives oh it's so bad to the point
where she says I feel like her skin is
burning Oh what I have the Wicked Witch
of the West Hall of is she she's 18
months old her name is ideal yeah
dude things are tech desertic helps like
this is gonna she does take
antihistamines target to like alleviate
a little bit but it doesn't work fully
it'll just well delay the reaction so
she takes 15 second bath and like
there's really need to take that bath
McGavin yeah why is she did like a
chinchilla bath you know chinchillas
can't get wet so it so they took a bath
and powder yeah that's what they should
give her a milk bath well yeah her
parents are trying everything they can
cuz recently in October is when she was
diagnosed with aquagenic urticaria and
Arctic Aria is hives I thought that that
was so it develops like hives
immediately once her skin comes into
contact with water regardless of the
temperature she's put Scotchgard all
over her and then she could take a ship
that's all sucks man I know kids
isn't there like a shot that that well I
mean come on
doctors scienter come on modern medicine
Wow his IV okay Dan that's a cute ass
girl she don't even look real yeah super
cute okay she's from Minnesota me me saw
what about her saliva she lured you I'm
not sure they didn't mention so I'm glad
that she's her cheeks gonna red when she
cries she's pointing she can't even cry
she doesn't even know why it hurts those
cheeks are pretty damn cute though and
again you could see like it's like all
hyping up what she's thinking about that
she is pretty crazy
I had eczema from head to toe oh you
know the pain what's that uh like skin
rash yeah
dry skin and all that I mean it's the
best that it's ever been now but it
moved all over my body and I felt like a
reptile for how long all my life Wow
yeah but yours is kind of undercooked I
don't see any of it yeah I mean now it's
just here but it's barely it's just
scars now but my nephew has it too and
he's just scratching like a crackhead
all the time he's just always scratch
that was like me oh I'm just constantly
itching and in they're linking um severe
eczema to like ADHD and all that cuz
you're constantly anxious and scratching
and [ __ ] so you can't think straight
yeah so now they're saying that they'd
give her a bath twice a week and so
every time before they give her a bath
I'll give her it and it antihistamine oh
but it's still it's still effexor bath
man do a shower blast dress boom and
they get her ass right out in the
[ __ ] powder dry yeah I mean that's
what they're doing there's like quickly
like it's trying to go quick thing with
you well okay what about astronauts what
the astronauts do like they can't take
showers right so what did they do are
these like baby wipes or some oh but
they're also in incubated you know I
mean so they're not dealing with the
same elements that we do out of here how
about alcohol can you take an alcohol
bath who's thinking that yeah just get
like a like a well like that toner like
witch hazel - it smells yeah
bad bad on but those are solutions I
think they're like partly water and then
oh we got to find some other liquids
then that isn't water baby oil oh yeah
oil base or milk dirty earth because oil
attracts oh yeah this is pit bulls
Oliver pit like lavender maybe alcohol
base or something yeah one time I was
watching Jenny Jones remember Jenny
Jones yeah and it was a little girl that
was allergic to the Sun I was like oh
yeah outside so she plays outside at
night in the dark she can't go outside
dude I bet you her skin though is
perfect that's true no sun damage
whatsoever
looks like 12 and she's 40 I remember
talking about some school and I think it
was somewhere in the UK or something
where they had a school especially
designed for those kids that they can't
they're allergic to the Sun and like the
windows are UV goes like that movie with
the cool kid Minh but ours or the others
yeah but they turned out to be don't
tell them I told me wait the kids
couldn't see the sunlight and like
that's what drove her crazy yeah yeah
was it's a ghost yeah so now the mom
Thai seven-year-old mom Britney she
created a GoFundMe so they're trying to
raise enough money so they can move to a
new home that has a well and a purified
water system and central air so you
could limit the severity of her
daughter's reactions Dan go punya saving
a lot yeah it really is there's so many
like energies and things happening like
what's going on with the world man
natural selection isn't doing its job
anymore because we have like glass Mars
and we're like innovating too much so
it's like oh we got to think of some new
[ __ ] to kill people yeah the elements
are to me yeah or genetic you like we're
inventing too many things that save
people that should have yes
they should have nine weak genes to pass
on yeah yeah I'm not gonna complain
because I got like 40 of them oh yeah we
all do where else I'll be dead my
blindness [ __ ] weak ankles terrible back
I just got an urn yourself [ __ ] it thank
you huh bye coughing yeah for sure I
would have been eaten in the wild
immediately no or I would been the wise
chief whatever because I would do no
physical activity I just developed this
the whole time
I just seduced the biggest man like that
can they all taste like that's
protecting me cuz I don't have any
strength that's why you like Steve he's
so tall sure sure
you say Steve can't protect you no he
totally can but that's not why I liked
him I liked him cuz he's funny my ex was
five six oh I went from like this the
same height as me too like way up there
yeah so you really don't have any
standards for men aside from making like
if everyone just looks like walking
blobs and then they make me laugh and
they're all a sudden like they're
handsome yeah it's like that black
mirror episode when everyone's blocked
they're just blobs until they laugh hey
you exist in the world
yeah like platonic platonic platonic
haha oh my gosh a person
here like me whoa that is so fascinating
man that's crazy
so you well but not that can understand
when things are attractive like if you
showed me a cover to cover of Vanity
Fair and you showed me like like Flavor
Flav like Flavor Flav he's fine he he
looks like a burnt match and like you're
telling me right now that he's ever made
me laugh well it not in the same way I
like that you make you laugh if he made
me laugh in that dried deadpan sense of
humor then yeah I would probably say oh
yeah because I like I like some pretty
old people like if you make me laugh-in
like that that deadpan dark humor way
there's not many people I can do that so
it's awesome good for you it's
fascinating
so if you saw Chris Hemsworth or Flavor
Flav and they both aren't saying
anything they're silent they're both
equally attractive to you I mean I can
understand that if Lee wouldn't be
attractive yeah I can't do it both don't
say anything
but I understand attractiveness like I
can say yeah I can say like he's got
attractive features he's symmetrical
like that's a model looking person like
I could say Tom Brady is very attractive
person
yeah I'm not attracted to him like in a
sex way but I have the movies back damn
that is crazy
I know right I wish every girl was like
that in this world I mean look at the
movies man like the [ __ ] prince and
the hottest princess gets with the Shrek
is usually a combo though it's like oh
he's cute and the best part about him is
that he has a great personality I feel
like it's way different cuz most people
it's like this at the combo it's more
that's might be like 60/40 70/30 yes for
you it's like 99 one yeah five six two
six four [ __ ] this to this well I
know through Wesley Snipes
it's like you guys are only thinking
physical right but I'm not I understand
it oh good dingo here's my theory the
younger you are the younger you are what
you're not that emotionally intelligent
at yet so my first crush was Jim Carrey
alright and my second crush was Adam
Sandler well that makes sense but
they're still younger looking they're
not George Carlin you know I mean like
oh that's the true they were younger but
they were like they just made me laugh
first yeah you know I gotta show you a
jack material with other girls and
they're like not a masturbate to this
magazine
it's just Adamson Dubois actually if
they have one magazine their fascination
around yeah you better believe if you
find that [ __ ] Jack material and
Isaac's backpacking like two or three
years they've all been jackin to girls
don't need Jack material because we have
our imaginations and like it's our
badges
like I understand like the horn but like
I don't need to have yeah like Bart was
saying like I understand the whole
personality thing and that's like the
good thing but I'm saying that you're
just so extreme like I feel like most
people have a mix of both you know I
mean like this person has to be it's
like yeah but he can't be this short or
I would like to be physically attracted
to at least yeah like I've heard from
millions of girls that they will have a
real is yeah million what the [ __ ] would
these millions of girls say are they a
lot of them say that they have a hard
time dating a guy that's shorter than
them that's very difficult yeah just say
but if they click emotionally those
things don't even matter because
physical doesn't mean that's what they
say yeah oh yeah that's right they're
true liars and then I think going back
to well saying the younger they are the
more they just I think they're more
physically attracted and they want that
image of what a hot guy is on the film
or whatever because they don't know
themselves yet when they become older
than the weird or [ __ ] they're attracted
to
I think Eminem's been a pretty long time
crush so use a normal crush he's a
normal crush he's funny
yeah I like all his punchlines in his
songs like that's what got me addicted
to puns and stuff cuz like he has really
good wordplay in like he's really funny
you are a sick freak you know what I
think the main thing is for the correct
me if I'm wrong yeah oh we will okay
it's alphas in there thing whatever
their thing is yeah so if they're great
comics for the thing that you like the
niche
yeah the dry humor or whatever or like
it's the athlete yeah the [ __ ] that you
like basketball players that's true or
whatever yeah okay yeah why in this room
alleys
[Music]